I made coffee and then I drank all of it
I didn't make coffee hey guys welcome to
drunk sports we've already got an hour
where winners win okay I love how it
looks for Chris to look so [ __ ] great
what what happened to the show what
happened what hasn't happened to it Sam
I woke up today with a [ __ ] bad back
I felt like a drone Bettis I felt like
with a bad day I had to lift me out of
the back because I did Pro Wrestling
this weekend oh hey Decco I mean I got
bad back that's how yeah that was Ella's
mania right yeah that's the brand off by
joining us is YouTube superstar if you
got question about YouTube you wanna
know some by YouTube call his wife it's
a loves talking it's all about the
tagging it's all about the title the
thumbnail I'll go into it later so what
I do in LA it's like because my I've
been blessed that people to bad-mouth me
and told me how to I you know get the
internet going so when I see my friends
and and I think they're really funny and
I see they're not doing so I like to sit
down and pound it into their head that
YouTube is the way to go so I've been
pounding into Stevens well-groomed head
I mean one of the best best here and
easily in comedy Thank You pounding into
his head for a year about getting his
youtube going and finally for some
reason it connected it's actually WW
youtube forward slash Steven Randall K
ste ve and ra and DOL pH so the videos a
day fun stuff there's it's kept one a
day you're going to couple I put like
three videos up a day I remember you
would just like do it all the time -
yeah everything just anything any videos
around the Comedy Store it's just hey if
you want to see my life if you want to
have a really fun time go to youtube
forward slash steven randolph yeah there
you go oh yeah there you go
I need subscriber it's gonna happen it's
all about the tagging right
tagging thumbnail pic yeah from Idol for
sure do you have any shows coming up
Steve I'm opening for steve-o at levity
live
may 17th and 18th I think that weekend
whatever that weekend is in Oxnard I'm
so happy for you I know it's really
sweet observe that thing I appreciate
that that's really sweet of him and my
brother to ask and I also be at
townhouse this Wednesday townhouse this
Wednesday brothels and Johnson's show
the show I love that the crowd always
hates me but I love it how you doing
Bronson they're drunk
no booze wah trash Chelsea goes I never
do well at that show and I go no it's
it's everybody just hammered and [ __ ]
up yeah she's fabulous killed so hard
one time really I never gave their
[ __ ] basely bowed out on stage really
yeah and I went up there and ate a dick
I've eaten a dick there a lot of times
yeah well you go up there because
they're like they're like rich guilty
white people my my that's my demographic
you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'm just
kidding me because they're like really
rich and they feel bad for ethnic people
because they're not like as rich as them
but they don't mind screwing them over
in business yeah well [ __ ] you over when
you're not looking but I'm so sorry
claiming equality in public are the
secret that's one of my first target on
a third my new special person tars
that's a hey no you were first yeah go
chase then I'm at the spoon in this fork
on the fiftieth and I'll be cuddling a
dork and uh pretty soon I hope so I have
some dates coming up but um so I have an
update my website so I don't know what
they're I'm so late you'll be around
I'll bet no I'm not gonna be wrong
you're in she very little needs I'm
staying home curious about it I'm
staying home I'm due south the gigs
usually takes 30 minutes I'm impressed
big change I'm a girl okay this broad
hey [ __ ] what are your date but just not
guys hey weird guide the back do you
have any dates
okay tell what if you want to see a
weird creepy ghost guy
doing an hour in Phoenix at Ritz Bar
June 25th Tuesday at 8 p.m. you're doing
an hour all right dude in Phoenix
multiple ripped shirts like that because
I feel like that is these are the
questions that a lot of the Comedy Store
is asking yeah as long as they wear out
or whatever they become too ripped and
then but do you buy them like that oh no
no and they yeah they wear out and then
I get a new one are you like do do you
treat your shirts like Jack Daniels
treats their [ __ ] liquor where
there's like 20 years the kid
impressions of nobody knows as I could
learn no what's your name again Chris
Chris [ __ ] he's not my show tomorrow
night and I couldn't remember I've been
on a show with you for eight years you
don't remember my name I do remember I
know when you do the list because all
the names are spelled wrong and I have
to tell like things are not perfect I'm
like that's not his spelling on the
Internet it's almost heartwarming it's
endearing you know I I don't mind his
like because he's so passionate like his
misspellings online no my problem is is
that Twitter has decided not to be like
everything else in the universe and auto
crash Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] at it by I
agree with you there because when I do a
typo I'm so embarrassed but what gains
here I'm you too bright yeah I'm a
YouTube guys since it's tough you can
edit your video what can way sorry
uploaded all right don't do it don't do
it once re-upload you can you can edit
your video now does that mess with the
analytics oh great and that's why 18,000
but once it gets to a hundred thousand
you don't want to man you edit it
interesting okay because the whole fear
of these guys like they're gonna they're
gonna chant something you're gonna tell
you guys which agendas entails the Jews
yeah yeah [ __ ] the gays write that [ __ ]
out right off the bat I'm totally with
you on the both things you just said I
feel were you saying that everyone shots
taking a turn since I've been here yeah
and I don't hear let's just say ways
okay okay
welcome our new sponsors to show we're
really excited to have a man that's very
excited about that's fair that's right
we are super excited to have our new
sponsors zip recruiter guys how hard is
it to get hired I mean it's possible I
have multiple friends that are currently
looking for jobs and I'm like hey if you
know of anything
hit me up and where should they go I'm
not even kidding well you know it's
something that lets say you're hiring
like dude you're gonna build a studio
you're obviously gonna need some people
to work with you yeah on your YouTube
channel
yes yeah and I add I'm a guy who brings
you Eminem Yeah right yes green M&M
rawhide Korea no [ __ ] red they get
fired gone you would maybe hire Aaron
but you can't hire Aaron cuz he's going
through a very expensive divorce soon I
hear ya so Aaron really oh you got go
somewhere where you can just get the
best of the best
yes why we're proud to have SIPP
recruiter how do you spell that
okay that's a great question leading job
board but they don't stop there
oh no there's more with with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply for your job
as applicants come in zip recurrent
analyzes each one of them and spotlights
the top candidates so you never miss a
great match zip recurs so effective that
four out of five of employers who post
unzip occurs gets a qualified candidate
through their site within the first day
I can't believe it you know it's looking
to get hired yeah that's where you go
and right now our listeners can try zip
recruiter for free on with this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com / punch-drunk that's zip
recruiter pretty easy dot slash pom-pom
dr. Don / bumpy you my I um got spelled
punch-drunk they do zip recruiter comm
punch-drunk dude make it happened get
jobs a job I feel like this is before
after Wow Wow after Wow
hope gave up I am that's the meme I got
the best compliment from San Antonio
podcast bye buddy listen to that on all
things company um they go every time
with Gabe Killian and and they go the
funniest thing about Gabe Killian is
keep knows about if all my friends get
famous I'm like the new rich little
there's no famous impressionist anymore
have you noticed that like there's no
who's really famous now for just doing
that probably one guy that was a show on
10 years ago that's the only guy I could
think of yeah you know why cuz
everybody's just pretty now we're gonna
do an impression of a pretty person this
is my look at you get cosmetic stuff I
mean it's like it doesn't make it who is
a depression is no I don't think that's
a preacher - I was just thinking Jeff
Richards Lockhart oh you know Melissa
Villasenor oh yes Melissa bean is the
number one she's a number one she might
be who was bigger than her she like
Connie will start out slow in Saturday
night but now I feel like she's
dominating really I don't watch it is
she doing well she's one of my favorite
comic I love watching her so much I'm a
huge fan this makes us start from
nothing - it's from Whittier do you I'm
for passing when yours is it like you
know withers the deal you arrival at her
shade of brown no it's just cool it's
halfway to the beach like Whittier is a
that used to be were all like the low
riding cruising of the 70s and 80s that
was all Whittier I feel like she's
comfortable on this show now and that
they realized what kind of gold they
have he's a powerhouse yeah and they
just give her the right [ __ ] and she
crushes it if you see her later Lady
gaga
no no it's great I mean Lady Gaga's
obviously as we know Satanist but
besides that she was
really [ __ ] she nailed it she nailed
it I go I watched millisecond you know
what she's so good I think she eats kids
that's help it Wow
is that how you have to get good yeah
dude I eat some kids rod I swear to God
a thousand I would eat a live baby right
now live on air I love her we only knew
anybody I had a baby I love her
personation for grandma have you heard
it she's funny cuz we heard it so many
times it's just so funny mean Chelsea do
back and forth Sophie knows Hispanic and
doesn't look at it like it at all who
Aaron darling you know her the comedian
you know her she's like a really hot
female comic doesn't ring a bell
I pie no fights are super hispanic comes
on the store lot i haven't seen her
lately you know so funny ID i left my
phone here what was that last wednesday
did I leave my phone here Ash Wednesday
for how long so I left the phone that
has all my social media on it I left it
I didn't get it to let last night The
Comedy Store how you did haven't had a
phone for that Noah has two dozen have
that's why I was confused too but that
means you put your social I look at my
answer and I haven't posting days I've
been staring at black strippers forever
[Laughter]
ah wonder why he looks so fresh and so
clean my life for such case tell me
about the resin tank I'll know I just my
girlfriend had to help me out of bed
like I was a 11-year running back at
like an NFL game different than normal
how did the wrestling thing go it was
fun with Mark Ellis no no on Ellis Jason
L shell although I'm all your stories
yeah
dad loved you know Mike Tully at all
okay well then you're done stories tell
your wife I said I owe her a fax haha
so uh this week I get a call Vegas knows
less it was in us it was just outside of
uh just outside of Ellendale Speedway
yeah yeah yeah of course with a beer you
didn't you there right I would like
partied there I almost got it oops I
used to steal copper wire there right
it's almost at the fringes of that area
that was we know the Budweiser plants
there so the kid five you roll down your
window and smell the it brewing that's
how you knew you're gonna be an
alcoholic
roll down the windows what oh wait wait
actually Miller was it Miller
that's Miller time we Budweiser's in
Northridge
we just glossed over almost got a girl
pregnant it right there um I dumped in a
girl in 1999 hit me and she raid her
insides with your warm milk yeah it and
she her all her sisters came to the door
and they all had kids and they all
looked at her and they're all like
progressively one or two years later you
open it yeah and I remember being like
don't come in her you're gonna have a
kid and I did in the night and you
waited that out out at the time
19:19 yeah [ __ ] this girl we're gonna
[ __ ] in a car so yeah they caught my
truck your lime yeah and you know and
you go come on Steve you know better
than this just don't come don't do it
and I did it and yeah I got uh uh baby
made a boom-boom it was this was before
cell phones everybody had him so I was
working at Trader Joe's I was just
waiting for that call every time they
drank I'd beg for a month
listening to a land mine at a job you
hate
/ or not every time the phone rang you
had a memory of Keio how you survived
living in Southern Cal God wanted me I
would have died yeah I mean that dude to
get [ __ ] up man where I'm from wheat
you have to go brave the cold in the
forest Wow
we had the drink in the forest Wow
because there's just nowhere to drink
right you have to go like oh it's going
over one of us says get eaten by Walt
that was a big I used to drink on the
beach where not when I was 17 MMH
yeah I grew up right on Lake Michigan I
grew up right on the beach oh did I yeah
yeah that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] we had to go
into the final week ago in the woods but
into the wheat what we did going to do
Mike's out out to my cousin Ross he
looked exactly like me when I was 17 he
was 21 did you come and he gave me his
hahaha he gave his driver's license and
he was like I'm giving this to you if
you [ __ ] me you're dead because he'd
beat the [ __ ] out of us so I I had I was
21 when I was 17 it was a real ID it
looked exactly like me so I was just
going to give it to you Oh Jonah solid
doing a drink and then I got arrested
for burning trash in San in Santa
Barbara you who I press come wag no I
was doing a prank in this whole thing a
little fire and I got arrested and then
they're like who are you Ross Driscoll
or Steve Randolph I'm like Steve ran off
to like import they gave me another
charge and I just I wasn't even scared
of prison I was scared of my cousin
another charge for having two IDs right
they're like oh you're impersonating or
whatever it was like oh you oh you're
stealing IDs so I didn't I didn't I did
how did you how did they get both of
your ID had both of on me I got arrested
I got arrested I didn't have you because
when I would go buy beer I present the
the fake ID they went through your
wallet get arrested
I got a rest yeah I was a junior for
lighting track like it was so stupid I
like these people insane I'm firing oh
they're lighting up they're lighting up
mattress on fire I threw a piece of
trash I was hammered and I walked by go
you idiots you gotta let it because
they're trying to it was like a prank
that people do in Santa Barbara I'm like
you got a wad of paper and sometime I
found paper and I threw it onto the
mattresses like it in the Simpsons or
something it just went and then I was
like that's how you do it I walked away
and I got tackled by cop leave you're
getting some guns dude are you yeah are
you working out I out I haven't worked
out in a week oh but look at those
gone I know some gun I noticed that
earlier when we were dancing again dude
I'm like why is he wearing a Popeye
shirt right now Wow look at it
I do look like you just went to the
beach in 1920 looks like she loves me
too you know it looks like a we just
peaked make a video out of that back to
Armageddon yeah so so so you go there so
yeah those that was wrestling names Oh
phenomenal so yeah I put out the double
the double special I put out the
segment's called arm oh that's amazing
name it's my Christmas Spectacular I
have a Christmas album thank you thank
you yeah so um was Bruce Willis's
Christmas movie everyone debates it what
I heart die die hard okay so I came up
with the name Armageddon that's what I
called it I'm a huge fan Armos that's
that's so funny right cuz like I
couldn't tell which name I wanted to
name the album i eight can tell if i
want the name of zero [ __ ] her
Armageddon it's the best name so I said
[ __ ] I'll break him in half and I'll
name him both yeah and so I get a call
from jason Ellis was like bro or Pro
Wrestling you want to do I'm like [ __ ]
yeah you go what's gonna be your name
I'm like arm Oh get in dude okay so uh
dude
it was one of the most fun things I've
ever done Mike Catherwood you know he
was on love lines forever
we did it it seemed like really in high
school I dated her after him she was a
squirter and it was insane and I
whenever I see him like on Billboard's
or something I was like that guy knows
if she was the gnarliest squirter of all
like where it would just he's insanely
good-looking and yes
[ __ ] shredded now I mean he's sober
too is yeah oh yeah just I don't know
him know him but I knew that she dated
him afterwards and he was on Loveline I
was like that guy knows about the spray
that's all I think about when I see him
I'd be covered I'd come home and my mom
and beg what the [ __ ] is going on you
know I was like it's sprite you know and
she a Thursday I don't know you're
looking a BA
I dated a squirter and it was it was an
extreme reason I like Siberia it was
like a the pornstar site theory it was
it was an extreme she was in his extreme
squirter worth everything it would look
like you ran through sprinklers when he
came home and I lived at home when I was
dating her my mom was just like did you
like what you loved it Jeff dated when
he said he hated he said you would have
to clean all his bedding you'd have to
put down a towel the towel is it enough
you have to make you feel better about
it was like like go to sleep afterwards
it was like somebody punctured a
waterbed that's exactly what it was yeah
my car was just covered my mom was like
I would wake up like pruney yeah
greatest to my some of the greatest
comedy nights of my life which well one
did and they're both
honestly some of the best times in
Phoenix Arizona I mean like very young
comic that's the best place to go and
just get [ __ ] weird you know yeah and
I used to be part of the Arabian Nights
that later went on to become X evil bugs
to Americans so they kicked me out and
they put another guy in there which was
very unceremonious who is the
replacement ah
Dino badami like I [ __ ] his last name
but he's up I think he's Palestinian out
of New York City was writing on a daily
show for a long time so anyways I get
kicked out but they decide to bring you
back for I'm gonna show him Phoenix and
then I love him I'm cool that yeah so we
show up and like you know I got the name
pelvis for mosque which is Persian Elvis
pelvis yeah because when he shows up it
isn't a vet in the Persian community oh
yeah I'm care where you are you know
Monster Mile
oh yeah oh yeah right everywhere they go
all his fans when they come into the
comedy store I want the best seat it's
like you're an hour late for the show
that's fine they want the best so they
see yeah we were all what we're sold out
show's over does not matter to me the
bests so these two dude show up in
[ __ ] phantoms like one of those
Bentley's or Rolls Royces phantoms two
of them Wow Drive Maserati Wow Wow the
Bentley Wow
the show he must do the bit shows he
must do or probably insane right like
some dude from the from like the Middle
East I want Maz over yeah no wow he's
such a nice guy he's so funny you know
like when the new Knights who blow up
and never change I really like him ya
know never change they're always like
that Steve Rannazzisi Randy and Bryan
Callen and Russell Peters yeah Russell
just those guys are that I'd only knew
him is blown up but he's like nicest
yeah all those guys are some guys so so
these guys show up well at this time
some white chick is following around and
she wants yeah I used to work for Big
Brother magazine as a skateboarding
magazine it was all comedy and no one
ever did skating ever just show someone
kickflipping maybe okay cool that's done
like it's like this is like sponges like
The Weather Channel that has like
murdered television that's way expansion
so funny so anyways so so why did I tell
this story I don't even know but anyway
so my manager now is Candice she's
sitting here this white girl sitting
here I'm sit in the back she just starts
grabbing my junk right there in front of
everybody I'm like what
yeah away the car dry around she starts
grabbing my junk and just like right and
gonna like licking my ear in front of
every time like what is going on here
did you get hard dude my twenties then
well that was like that I think was
early 30s so so I'm in this belly man
everybody gets out she says stay here
dude she starts blowing me right there
in the Bentley then I start [ __ ]
hitting it right there in the Bentley
god nobody loves [ __ ] cars more than
you bro [ __ ] sprinklers oh my god in
the [ __ ] guys in the Bentley or free
up Lisa
go [ __ ] the other car oh you're
[ __ ] yeah that's next-level money
dude this is not the [ __ ] car my
friend this is the nayad not [ __ ] in
the foot car yeah we buy the [ __ ]
drive car that is [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] drive car your new driving
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
so Jason else if you don't know him he
has an awesome show I I work with Jason
else on Spike TV and we've been friends
ever since and he asked me he goes hey
you know I do the single [ __ ] yet if you
ever been through jason Ellis shell you
you would love it's like I've heard that
name I think I've seen him on line up
slowly come out he's bisexual he's like
super [ __ ] tatted and the chicks all
around him are [ __ ] like smoke shows
yeah his wife is just gorgeous they're
both the kind of guy that flux in a
drive car and yeah I've got a [ __ ] car
that's my kind of guy Ultimate Fighter
no nobody want to be but he likes the
box he likes to all this pretty scary
dude he's actually the nicest dude ever
but he covered her breath covered his
head's concise bisexual that's scary
that guy wants it he's getting it yeah
it's a nice either way
hey uh check please
Jason shark heart Ellis I don't want any
problems rub you buddy like don't want
shiny problems
shark heart is a great nickname that is
a great name so so he calls me up we do
it we rehearse man and it's like the
hits are real - yeah you wrestled him no
yeah is there any video of this yeah
it's out I love to see it I think it's
on the Internet
I can't fight on the word is really I
would love to see it yeah someday
someday but so we show up mostly as
people boxing each other's acting just
fans getting the ring and they beat the
[ __ ] out of each other I love you guys
like cozy Louise I love to go there's
[ __ ] correct where is it that like
the 909 do it right that's where that
[ __ ] goes down like that's what around
the edge of the 6 to 6 any further and
it's just mayhem which is motorbikes
meth and [ __ ] fighting people and
backyard dude there is some white trash
down that way everybody thinks
California's like whoa surfer dude no no
it's like bro I got tats let me suck
your dick dude you know what's so funny
you guys have to have them on the show
cuz they'll come here and do any we
won't you talk with Josh wolf my brother
goes because my brother tours of steve-o
he's like aw dude you need to meet these
[ __ ] kids that are like jackass style
kids out in the middle of nowhere in
Utah that just hurt themselves real bad
I'll put you in touch with them so I
mean Josh wolf I asked him I'm like do
you wanna be in touch with these guys
he's like absolutely they happen to be
like a quarter-mile from wise guys
comedy club we get to their back yard
they're like I love your brothers Scott
Randolph and like so here's what we
could do you can staple firework to our
head I'll jump off that [ __ ] I almost
died jumping off the roof during
Christmas my lungs filled up with blood
I was in a coma and flatline so I don't
want to hit that roof I kind of kind of
weird energy around it but anything else
in the game Josh wolf is like amazing
you know like if we had all these kids I
was just talking to him about it but
really he didn't tell me this story but
he goes dude I just what took Randolph
on the road I'm like it was I love that
guy he goes that guy's crazy I don't
have no idea have you seen this new
bathing suit
I'm bathing in jokes but they ended up
lighting themselves on fire in a bunny
suit jumped off a [ __ ] thing onto
their nuts we Josh staple the firework
to the guy's head I lit it blew his
[ __ ] forehead ey what are you gonna
kill it I was so scared of the stapler
gloves ID yeah yeah Ross is going wrong
John say no yeah that's that's just that
that like crazy life that's so wild
these guys staple the firework to do it
and blew it off that's the I posted that
yeah yeah okay now I know what that was
from I thought that was like some old
skulls like we got nothing else to do
yeah I got the next 60 years got nothing
planned and there's a goring in that
town where people like I mean yeah man
old Tyler that cliff and that's a Cuyler
my balls
nobody show on them what's that yeah I
think they were on an MTV show with with
Zach ass that big kid Zach yeah yeah he
was like steve-o's protege he's got to
be like 300 pounds and his name is Zach
ass and he has a show out right now and
these guys were all on the show so
they're all in this this empty beaches
it's just a weird world out there dude
why are you in this [ __ ] bubble where
everybody's like hey dude there's some
rules we gotta follow it let's not break
the rules Utah's not playing by those
rules you tell is not playing by those
rules
it's [ __ ] nuts out there its third
world out there bro it's beautiful
though it know you got beautiful Utah is
very beautiful you know that
do you know why the Mormon Church is in
Utah please tell us I hope it ask deal
with that Mike brought on a Donnie guy
that runs this place or building flirt
what's it's got I don't give up fun
sometimes you gotta let me know what the
joke is so I can understand what we're
doing right now is a weird episode no
it's a great episode
except for in James great writings
people what is the joke I want to fight
everybody that works here
what'd they do to you what where'd they
touch you wait I haven't touched me is
it are you still mad because it lets you
hook up with that dragon lady
unfortunate
I blame them with the town big J
Caldecott I can't remember she is like a
skeptic a sight to behold
I don't remember he had the funniest
she's pretty I was horrible yeah she's
like I didn't [ __ ] her I ate her [ __ ]
and then you retracted he was like
trolling her even though he's crazy
Bryan Callen goes you don't know who he
is
you don't I by the way count
I think he's getting divorced no way
that's not public knowledge he doesn't
even say that on the show oh that I
guess it's not oh that's friend info
wait I know this is gonna sound crazy
but hey I gotta do another read oh I was
gonna say back to your boy hey guys our
new sponsors divorce lawyers calm see
how I did that that's good that's good
so so anyway so that was the whole
squirt story but back to this who are
you calling now his whole thing is just
like nothing but like girls who dance at
Jumbo's clown room though the wrestling
yeah yeah so all the obvious like crew
it's like a little the gorgeous ladies
of rest
they're just hot tatted chicks yeah
they're smoking hot they all just love
the six pack each other when they hang
out girls do that like what
well boom they're just six package I
mean okay I'm glad I don't know thank
you yeah but I'm all [ __ ] like when you
go like back in the old days when you're
grabbing saw yeah yeah a six-pack of
soda yeah I've never heard that term but
I know yeah so they sit well they just
get one in the [ __ ] one in the you
know I'm saying so sports podcast ever
yeah so they you know you'd watch these
people box and he's you know they they
just they're fans at least like the
fighter they want the car chase analysis
thanks sure so then we were the last
thing and I was Armageddon dude I want
to do this I came out and you were the
last one around our match with wasn't
all wrestling where they doing bono
there by last one was wrestling this no
it was else it was a small private Ellis
mania okay but there there's boxing and
MMA yeah it was boxing all the way up to
the end okay so you're a wrestling one
yes I want to do it do it's fun I want
to do it I'm telling you it's fun
it sounds really fun it's so wait so you
guys had like rehearse and choreograph a
bunch of times okay how many times did
you like rehearse or come up with five
or six and how long was the match if you
never beat 20 minutes 20 minutes you
guys are ready funky I want to start
China white weird to tag-team will fight
anybody I'm calling it out Jason laughs
Erin I'm calling it a Vernon has been a
laughs since is this divorced art I've
got over the years they're the funniest
thing on international bad boys he's
doing it now we were talking about
terminator and he just did the thumbs up
and down on to his modern no one else I
don't know they said that little wall
don't see you that was the funniest
thing I've ever seen on a pot I do
didn't you and I were the only ones that
knew it existed I do feel like Erin was
a lot closer in the other studio like
you like you've never been to love and
talk yeah like that he got married I
like that they got him in a [ __ ] cab
over there see his eyes so the little
connection dude he's always giving you
help me I'm trapped
look I deal with your lives got the most
honest eyes to deal with your [ __ ]
lies yeah Betty Davis huh huh
so mr. [ __ ]
gotta do so no we went there and uh I
mean Mike Catherwood and jail
Jason else just don't give a [ __ ]
they're kind of like the Utah guys like
don't do anything I'm like yeah I I go
I'll do anything I don't want to get
paralyzed that's the only thing I told
them ain't no head drop did you jump off
the top rope or anything ah once I did
something I kind up and I he was like
how was is it fun when you got up the
chair that you can barely move you're
like wrestlers trained for years to
learn to not hurt each other yeah yes
yeah five times I mean how many times my
life am I gonna be able to do pro
wrestling at least once yeah that's it
no that's it so uh it was pretty cool
who won the match of course Ellis yeah
guy yeah sure well they're called what's
it called antiquing is that what's
called when you like when you go buy old
products and old things I don't that is
wrestling but when they throw stuff in
your face there's like a term for it
like dust or something yeah I don't even
know but we do it so the first time we
do it is we're all beating at me and my
cathodes were beating where legally
beating up jason Ellis right so then it
attacked him man yeah I haven't had to
go out and like the only thing good fine
was to a pulse right oh yeah I'm
Armenian so it got me more power I like
yeah yeah holy Sam huh would find a way
to work cocaine into a wrestling yeah
yeah then the second time is up I got it
spinach he's been beating a chamois and
I roll over and my buddy was my fake
Armenian friend he gave my Catherine
with some chakkar Cologne
I took the bottle and I'm like you your
wrestling moves oh that's so funny
hilari it was fun dude that's really fun
but the only time like I felt is when
jason Ellis like [ __ ] ran and tackled
me
a little too high and like it was it
wasn't the right ring it hurt I I mean
it did hurt but I felt I mean like his
shoulder went into my deal that's
shocking yeah and then the whole night I
dreamed I could never close my job I was
gonna ask him if anybody other than your
back being bad if anybody got like
accidentally hurt or no no punches
really landing no no no me and funk
child we're team China white we
challenge anybody I'm gonna fight
whoever wants to [ __ ] get in the ring
with us who you want fight who you guys
who if you can fight anyone at the time
so who'd you fight oh it's at the Comedy
Store and yeah yeah I'm calling out
anybody like everyone involved somebody
out on the pro wrestling Matt Matt
Lockwood and tilling and take door guys
not tape he loves challenging tape
speaking eight love k-band coffee dude
why don't you marry an addicted a
caveman I'm addicted caveman coffee to
and you can use the code punch drunk and
that'll save you 15 oh yeah caveman
coffee every single morning yeah I chose
nitro nitro yeah I rose great the closer
just boom I I have another cold brew
every single morning for like the first
two years that came in coffee they were
consistently sold out like really pretty
much only get them if right when they
restock them you keep man coffee with no
sexual flavors Wow
- Tate yeah but now that now they have
them other times well I just rather pay
the four bucks
so - give me a coffee that I came in
coffee calm love you trunk
do you love 15% huh I love tape very
much that's time last night I look I'd
love to marry tape yeah I go watch that
he'll make an honest woman out of me
that's the pirate's life what else is
going on
do I talk can I tell the story about the
Chelsea nice first date have I told you
that story tell the story why don't you
tell us sorry well you go use the
bathroom back right after this break
okay so so rude go ahead yeah I just say
first you and Chelsea are my favorite
comedy couple really oh you're my top 20
I tell her every time I see her - like I
loved when I worked the comedy store
with her and I could just like gossip on
would you consider
yeah she loved would you consider yeah
the best thank you I tell you tell the
best stories really yeah so like I
already know you're talking but no
that's rude Chelsea would you configure
yourself Tommy would you consider
yourself a comedy couple oh I mean I
guess yeah I'm not yeah but I'm not
involved like she actually does comedy
so yeah but I mean we know this you're
very involved in the comedy world you're
right on my favorite comedy couple there
you go you look exactly like Jim
Carrey's daughter do you wait is she
pretty though yeah she's pretty okay
yeah yeah I thought well I thought it
was I've mistaken her for you before I'm
like eh what's up what's up and she's
like hey because I've met her a few
times the baby yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh she does yeah so funny so just
keeps going I've done like like I've
gotten into her because I'm like
personal with you and I've gotten like
really personal with her and she was
like I know you but whoa like and I was
like oh it's not her I swear to God
have you seen the picture of her to her
no did she look here let's pull it up
that's so funny
she looks exactly like Candace but day
ige I could I could see that hold on let
me see you do look a lot like it's crazy
and she is cute too ya know she's dating
somebody at the store yeah she was
dating what's his name phrase I don't
know that she have a baby with the guy
at the store - no no calm down it was
like we should be best hello we're best
machine but she is a baby as a product
from her mom and her dad meeting at the
store a belly rub his connections her
mom used to be a waiter of waitress
there okay she looks a lot like her dad
though in a good way but like she looks
like her death
yeah that's Candace crazy I know oh oh
the other one yeah that does look like
you so this is appropriate tell stories
like have I told this or tell it no so
yeah we never repeat stories on punch oh
is this even sports
this is our favorite episodes what no
they like this better Samson control is
just NBA for an hour straight of the
same like he's trying to make the same
point to people that are like arguing
against him we're just like yeah we get
it
LeBron we get it but let's not mention
it while he's gone
go ahead tell your so okay so gonna get
him going so uh who's calling you Kevin
Blatt Kevin Blatt everybody KB KB you're
on speaker you're on punch-drunk what's
up what's up baby it's just about to get
into the [ __ ] story yeah you got it
hey [ __ ] how are you good good he's
got a podcast with two short Devo that's
right I know okay oh yeah I just did
Jeremiah's podcast myself alright hey
I'll call you back afterwards this is
about work about credit card stuff
alright we got another one up I'll call
you later bye there I saw credit card
processing during the game running a
credit card scam no I sell credit card
oh if you guys are merchants out there
and you need credit card processing if
you're a bad boy out there I don't care
what you're selling within the confines
of the law there's no judgment with my
company DME steven randolph - on
instagram I will get you processing
ecommerce crazy [ __ ] anyways so we
haven't even started Sam back to here we
waited for you - Sam loves a good
[ __ ] story you think Sam doesn't like
no Stan well he just went off the rails
like we always Kevin black calls we too
were talking to him while he's been
referring me a lot of credit card deals
Oh have you done his podcasts are too
short
yeah I don't understand why it doesn't
have more listeners it's it's too short
it's weird like I did it it looks kinda
weird it's not a weird thing is not as
weird it's not getting out to the world
see here's the problem man - wants
people to come listen to - so they want
to keep it is that that one up on
Cahuenga dreams incredible lack it's a
nice building you know that's - what's
the same way vh1 did remember
one used to be everybody on a video
would remember they look like him and
they were talking about the 80s they
were doing coke bad boys of rock all
[ __ ] hot light-skinned black chicks
vh1 went black
don't tell the story Adam get more
coffee do you see it anymore
so uh it went black yeah I don't like
cuz I did I did the podcast with Kevin -
sure it was great episode is so bun it's
[ __ ] too short Kevin black great guys
I'm like how come and no one come you
know you know when you're on a good
podcast people will message you back you
know IRC you and be like hey they heard
you're not one person said anything so
I'm like this isn't getting out there
it's great content they're kicking ass I
don't understand how it no one's [ __ ]
here it's the greatest podcast that was
a weird thing because it's like - radio
and their big calls that all the Fords
are gonna have - radio in them but
they've got draws a fort
well Middle America does but do they
want listen to the donkey brand I'll
talk about [ __ ] no it's fine I'm fine
with butts like it's just now I don't
need it I don't get it it's like seaso
or something they know they wanted it to
be the competition too serious but they
got a window glass they got to get see
remember when you see your favorite
nightclub go all black you're like well
that'll be closed in two weeks
wow that's racism no it's not it's
called it yeah maybe I got called a
racist
this morning I got calls yesterday by
your girlfriend guys I might start over
what'd I miss
okay welcome you know you're not at a
good taco truck unless you feel unsafe
oh yeah just put that that's true it is
true I'm born raised in Los Angeles dude
like all it dated is latina is like like
like two latin girls like see there
that's the white mantle and they're like
talking [ __ ] about me on Facebook I was
like excuse me and they're like just a
white man talking about [ __ ] I'm like
taco trucks in terrible areas are the
best I don't know do i unsee that do I
know I think they're just so lazy that
when one is great
that's the sunset what's the best one
and it wasn't even Hispanic but they
have a Hopf they're a bad guard guys if
you're from out of town Hollywood is not
safe Beverly Hills is and you're on
Sunset in western be careful between
your York
a taco truck has an armed guard yes leo
absolutely the bat my favorite Boulevard
was bragging the Hollywood Boulevard
like Hollywood's bragging at Hollywood
Boulevard was voted a top 100 tourist
destination but what they didn't tell
you they were 100 out of 100 like they
were voting on the worst tourist place
of the most famous places ever
that's like dude if you like if your
thing about be going to Hollywood to be
a Dora go to eat always try to go I know
when I get murdered no I tell you that
story seven years murder oh yeah I
remember that when I was literally the
guide the first guy to come up to a guy
that was dying that happens Oh father
were you at the economy so when the
shots happened to that was there yet
okay so anywhere you are
I dare someone to come murder I'm
working at The Comedy Store it stores
all time right no like a what's there to
do I'm like where the comedy store is
this is the edge of safety that's
Beverly oh that's nice go to the Rainbow
Room go over there it's bad and they're
like okay okay it's East Hollywood is
dude I'll go to Compton I filmed the
prank video in Compton head-on Samar had
zero problems with dog we had fun ever
he's like oh welcome to Compton much
love would you know these dogs I got
suck I every - I love that God so fun
he's living in Austin oh yeah he moved
to Austin I love to do now not comedy
he's so funny
what's he doing so far just blow and
dude just blowing dudes yeah dude we
should call him up yeah hey goddess what
was y'all erica was like the hey girl
the first video we ever walked wrote
that nobody uh nobody ever watch was a
pack that out it's so funny so funny how
much money a minute man god that's such
a funny video post that I'm saying I
could tweet it so people know I was here
guy going home every other [ __ ] week
what are you doing dog picks up he does
this thing gross or fierce on my podcast
he calls any
say a word and he'll tell you if it's
gross her fears like diet coke is it
fears tweeted him it's a grocer fear yes
I worked at a restaurant with him I
worked at a restaurant with him and he
Buick is that's gross that's fierce I'm
here to say a word you're like you're
like target he's like it's fierce like
this it's gross you know it's like it's
gross in fierce that's difficult I don't
want to talk about it so he's already
called into my podcast and fans are
tweeting at him it's at Dodd bless you
do D really I'll ESS why are you just
tweet at Dodd gross her fear one word
and hopefully Pisco some fears but yeah
East Hollywood these girls like cut [ __ ]
on me on Facebook and call me racist for
saying that taco trucks in bad areas so
yesterday I did a show I had a couple
crazy yeah I mean like I hate that race
I hated like oh you're white you can't
discuss this what the [ __ ] they had an
arrow pointing up in the comment section
going a total white guy and I was like
ah that's the truth and all the Mexicans
on the page well I don't know so funny
so true I don't understand what's races
about that you got people that are bored
and have nothing else in life they're
going on to so they're just clinging on
to that
it's like um is it like everybody's
opinion is equal yeah so like one random
person I internet calls you racist all
of a sudden that's that's um seriously
dated Latinas I Mexicans are my best
friends taco trucks a terrible yeah
terrible areas are my best friends
they're my people out of every job I've
always worked at restaurants I grew up I
came of age in a restaurant I learned
how to smoke weed and do coke with the
Mexican there there there if you flash
back when I die as a part of my life
like that American Beauty thing they'll
be like the first major stills will be
me partying and hanging out learning how
to be an adult through Mexicans I don't
know max you put a hit out on me one
time in Vegas finally someone did some
no really are you guys yeah see up my
liquid on you for half of this story I
used to work at this restaurant called
boogies diner in how you know Vegas in
the Caesars forum that's racist and like
I got along with everybody but there's a
small group of people that didn't like
me dude and there were some [ __ ]
gangbangers there and this one dudes
like hey dude we got we should I mean
dead serious they're like
which takes him [ __ ] out I'm serious
dude why though what year is it because
I was a [ __ ] talking [ __ ] monster
back in the day and the 90s like one
glad things have changed wow we're
talking about like 96 yeah yeah these
Mexicans and this one guy that cooked
like me put it he Knicks he's only high
up in the [ __ ] gang - Wow like nah
dude he's just a [ __ ] talker don't
[ __ ] kill the what don't kill him
don't kill the wipe how did you find out
they were gonna kill you because he told
me they're gonna kill all the kitchen
guys and it's not that's not they would
do it and go right back to their job and
not even think about God I get it thank
you it was the greatest worst job I ever
had work in a bookies diner I love
working at restaurant okay anymore so
there's like but it's a restaurant and
then was high-end [ __ ] fashion place
and we're him in there were like 11 how
did you get laid there ah yeah but not
from them did you [ __ ] in that
established no I didn't know you did I
jacked off in the bathroom I did not and
you're talking did you but yeah I didn't
what I wasn't big jerk-off then because
I was literally [ __ ] so much I didn't
have - yeah I'm Wow there I thought
Debra dude when I tell you man did I
stopped counting at 200 people did you
[ __ ] me and you're at 200 in the early
nineteen nine that's what AIDS was
flarin bro yeah look I was in [ __ ]
guys in the ass baby the worry about
that's racist yeah but dude I mean dude
these chicks were like super super tense
and they would eat their food and then
they would they wouldn't eat it all cuz
their model and you just eat off it just
sorry they're like yeah you eat our food
I go I really like your [ __ ] yeah
that's a no-no him afraid what goes in
your mouth dude my hands are tingling in
my armpits hurt do you think that's a
disease I think that means you're dying
I'm getting anxiety probably getting
some of that scurvy okay yeah take it
easy Gatsby my next trick yeah dude so
okay so so in jail see now his first day
at the [ __ ] can I just tell you guys
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm trying
to get out and hang out of this story
one second right
right after this break I'd like to hear
together guys this story I've heard
before it's brought to you by good
friends of bet TSI head Diaz hi bet
these hi frog your back needs go to
Betty so I use the promo code punched
2525 you get $25 what can make a bet
will Steve Randolph ever tell the story
will you ever tell the story guys
seriously it's hot right now I need NBA
playoffs UFC boxing baseball's heating
up Kentucky trying to tell the story it
is the time to [ __ ] him make your bets
now some of you guys hit us up and get
really mad because you've tried to make
a bet and maybe you couldn't pull your
money right now if you opt into the
bonus which are giving you some extra
cash you have to bet a certain amount of
money and only it's only logical it's
only logical because I could do is I'll
double up to 500 bucks so if you put in
500 and they double that naive $1,000
Matt West pull it out you can't pull ya
gotta I hope their credit card
processing is pretty secure because I
love processing for gaming industry
gaming industry Guns & Ammo kratom I
don't care what you're selling I'll help
you process that online go ahead okay
working advertisement into our
advertisements Jenna co-payments on
cosets the name your thing yeah Wow
that's another sponsor on the new show
buddy so that's it so go to bed TSI make
those bats we gotta get back to dudes
from UFC credit card there's another we
actually got that free UFC it's so bad
it doesn't load and you're telling me to
get it so you looks like mint if a pay
five dollars a month for something that
doesn't worry me you're like you guys
can't afford five dollars a month I
don't want a new one
iPhone is this watch I don't even know
she had that when we were dating we've
been broken up for seven years wow
that's a nice that's not true is it Jeff
when I got the phone cuz I remember it
was rose gold and pretty and I brought
it to his house and I would put it up
like a shrine and be like look at her
rose gold
Wow cuz you're wrong yes that's why
won't you good bytes and I'm nowhere
near the stores I love this she's gotta
put a quarter in service here so I can't
look it up but it's rose and you don't
have service anywhere no I do but never
in here and the you I can't get the
Wi-Fi to work cuz it's what is the
longest password of all time the Wi-Fi
and make a bet see whether any time that
UFC ESPN Plus does not work for you
Sokka no yes my god TV that works this
is nothing to do with myself
our Wi-Fi makes everybody pay money for
something that does not so many people
DM me and say you need to talk about how
this is the worst streaming so people
demon you right now I can't watch like I
don't know
well then it goes to our point as we've
always said [ __ ] you yes he has tried
[ __ ] ruin sport okay
five dollars a month but it doesn't load
what happened with my Roku everything
works on it i netflix never had a
problem hey red bands here we're never
gonna give you guys here's static is it
red bands energy race he's on the show
you know I'm getting a static in my
headphones number two stop eating stop
eating your pizza we have an endless
amount of chairs here Brian
how are you Brian I'm great I uh you
know I was trying to get in here I heard
isn't that the best thing I always could
hear Sam yelling elders right you're
arguing the doorbell you like God so
sorry the door that's in it yeah I mean
yeah it's my own so I don't know if
you've heard that have you heard Steve's
[ __ ] story yet no yeah my first date
with Chelsea it was it ended crazies and
ruin your hair with the way you have
that Mike goes on right now it's gonna
ruin your hair I saw you coming right
now
mike is no static there's static in my
mind
static I didn't hear I don't hear it at
all I'll hear oh it's like all I hear
okay so you hear stack that means you
have AIDS
no that's what they say all right so so
back in the day I think I told it on
international bad boys I I won't go to
[ __ ] 's when I was on heroin right I
would shoot heroin only one looks for
activities wait wait wait you're like
that's a new app by the way activities
on heroin yeah I just go to [ __ ] I
wouldn't participate because I was just
limp wait how do you how does one know
of like was like you maybe some powers
and swell different [ __ ] oxygen it
was Jim powers you sick [ __ ] exactly
I've heard this story like I'm psychic
but you haven't heard the second story
when I went with Chelsea how good a
[ __ ] Jim powers he's he's the owner
of American [ __ ] he used to have like
he was really big back in the day he did
it all be like oh I'm just like I'm the
babysitter oh my god I'm gonna lose my
job I'll let ya know he just ran as a
director he's the director and producer
and he used to do all like he was
starting to do more than like the read
he like kind of pushed pouring into the
more like super like gonzo like really
like stunt father he had the [ __ ] hot
line you'd call this 800 number it was a
it was a [ __ ] hot line is like a
[ __ ] boys welcome to [ __ ] we'll be
at this this uh this location it was
crazy so you would call a phone number
and it'd be like go to I were will and
Lankershim and there'll be a [ __ ]
waiting for I worked a big brother
magazine which is owned by Larry Flynt
let later became jackass and I was like
jaded to porn so I was like I'll [ __ ] it
you know like I made the mistake of
being I was working at hustler like for
like two or three years when I was a kid
interning there I like did I've seen it
all I'm bored by this and some guy goes
you're bored by porn I'm like yeah he's
like you ever been to [ __ ]
called a [ __ ] hotline and I was like
and then when you're there that number I
don't remember you can google it I don't
know if that would help the story if I
could a good I could have [ __ ] called
abaca I don't even know if the [ __ ]
hotline exists do you think it will ever
die by then find out right Ben haha what
yours this that's about again I just do
this on
I don't need a new phone I love it don't
drop them out of my hands you're re -
mom I'm surprised you're not knitting
right now listening to her story Jeff's
phone is like a 400 Arsene mind you guys
are already your daughter's gonna be
such a great comic anyone's mom got an
iPhone 5 when I googled [ __ ] hotline
Los Angeles it comes up with Department
of Mental Health
Wow so when you're when you're [ __ ] a
girl with other people like is it is it
weird to see all the different kinds of
calm like is there like you know like
liquid guys there's a creamy one yes yes
yes yes as soon as we started talking
about it he's like a shark that smelled
blood he just smelled calm and he's like
[ __ ] who are you dog yeah so extra so
anyways I would wear the karate suit and
go to these [ __ ] so I went I was like
oh my god this amazing you had a [ __ ]
superhero alpha at the blood where you
know and I even asked Jim after I went
to my second one can I bring a film crew
into film make a funny video I wore
karate suit and interviewed the guys did
they call you jump on they call you
chunk Norris stop it chunky and I felt I
filmed this I made a funny video set it
to my dog girl still alive that did that
I don't know yeah yeah over and under
well note the new girl I she was just on
re manases podcast ago I popped on and
started crying but that's a part of the
second part of this story so okay so I
think it's too bad vibe for this potty
this isn't like this kind of this
podcast I don't know okay okay so so I
go and I start hanging out I show this
video I made at at UCB they had a [ __ ]
up in a legals video night in 2009 I
asked Matt Besser that's when you could
still kind of get out yeah he's one of
the guys that Upright Citizens Brigade
and he goes yeah come and show the video
I showed it everybody started booing and
he started throwing [ __ ] at me because
that was a really graphic video of me
interviewing
guys as they're coming on this girl's
face people start calling me a monster
throwing [ __ ] at me and they
they stopped the night after that never
thought about it again and then started
dating Chelsea to let you know I just
never I never want you I got sober so I
never went to [ __ ] again cocky
housewarming party oh my god our house
is a [ __ ] so then so then Chelsea
goes I started dating Chelsea I asked
her out she goes out wouldn't it be
funny if for our first date we would go
to [ __ ] so it's ten years later I'm
like yeah the guy texes me back and then
I like I had a bad feeling in my gut
like don't text this guy and I texted
Jim powers hey I don't know if you
remember me I used to intern at Big
Brother magazine are you I don't know if
your mommy's member chunk newest member
chunk Knorr and he just checked back a
picture of the flyer for [ __ ] 68 and
I was like oh boy yeah yeah he goes were
filming next week and I and I showed it
to Chelsea I was like oh man and
Chelsea's like let's go and so it was in
the valley and we both go this is like
two years ago my first date with Chelsea
yeah you know they're perfect for each
other if you even thought like on a
first date you would bring your good new
girl to like a [ __ ] I know and then
she would want to go it was crazy
so we walk in there taking promo
pictures of the girl something Jenna
white or something Jennifer why she's
the best well I loved that he looks at
you like Sam's that right one of the few
I know she actually came to a county
chaos one time and then tweeted after
I'm like hold on Jennifer white was that
comedy chaos and nobody told me she's a
super she's a superstar really oh yeah
she's next level well okay so so she's
in the best if we go to this [ __ ] if
you guys have ever been a becau you walk
into a Brian have you been to Phuket oh
I've never even watched one like online
rude why do I want to come on a girl's
face then just go I don't mind that I
just I'm more concerned about the other
11 guys doing it as well well I would
never go to another one Ross buyer I'll
never go to another one again I said how
many of you been to Bali five
one in sobriety I'll never do it again
That's not me what's the smell of a book
this was the sober one right
oh wait so you guys go it does yeah yeah
it's well it comes on Randolph you guys
go so we walk in and as are driving you
over what is she saying she's like
Hershey's Charlie's dressed up like a
[ __ ] ready to [ __ ] have some fun
and I'm like oh my god this is because I
really loved her you know and I was like
oh my still yeah by the way I learned
that Steve Randolph's wedding when
you're when you're asked to do standby
the wedding
do not do divorce jokes people do not
like that at a wedding you did great I
did one divorce show bombed I blamed it
on Dana
what did I do like it was just like so
like I didn't choke about how I wrote
them a check but I ran to like Brody set
was longer than the apples about
baseball but growing up in the valley
and what did you [ __ ] look he's even
pissed he's only kidding
how dare you you don't do that to me so
uh my friend made Brody a big thing for
the Comedy Store they dropped it off
last night it's made out of a bunch of
broken glass
that's very cool they're gonna hang it
up in I love it how big is that it's
huge it's like maybe uh four five people
I think he'll be a good singer Brody now
uh several photos you know why ha ha
here we go there we go you're always
there they're there no pull back a
little bit a little little you got it
who's your foot your friends Instagram
uh Ted months Mozart art yeah I'll just
yeah mosaic uh uh
just tweet it later yeah
yeah that is funny cuz there is Brody's
everywhere yeah I'm in the hall yeah we
have to win the belly room the back room
yeah
and now they'll have that belly room
he's everywhere yeah yeah yeah watch
dressed like a [ __ ] and watching a bunch
of guys come on your first date Brody
and a [ __ ] would be an amazing when
we were on the road we were doing social
justice warriors yeah [ __ ] Brody
would be in the backseat watching two
things either Infowars or hardcore
pornography I never seen that side of
him I can imagine yeah III decide with
you on this I can't imagine Brody in the
bags a gentleman do a video where you
just watch Brody watch porn I was great
I never knew that a Brody even the meds
were like made him unavailable to watch
porn or so he just made him uninterested
and we found his fleshlight remember we
found this dude that we went to Brody's
house to in his apartment to help go
through some of this stuff and Brian's
like oh look at I found a flashlight I
gave this to him did you did you try
taking it no no it smoked clean though
it was on you keep it you threw up
Brody's flashlight am I gonna throw that
online you can show that line guys know
if you saw online took the money gave to
suicide hotlines save the life yeah god
that's true
sure fleshlight calm yep um those things
are great I didn't throw mine away I
found an old one else really
I'm [ __ ] old like those melted in my
in my room because it was like my office
gets really hot during the summers
because I never air-conditioned my
office so I found one and it was just
melted it was gross it's melted put a
[ __ ] mm-hmm that thing was great so we
walk into the [ __ ] and they're in the
lobby is 40 dudes 30 to 40 dudes all
like it's like I take a number kind of
thing like a deli are these people all
yet that was an aim test so they're like
extras there's like doctors they are
streetwalker what do you mean an aim
test
sex time oh okay I think meant like your
actors 12-step program
I saw he would always saw him there he
freaked out Chelsea we saw him at a
12-step meeting he was like hey remember
me from the [ __ ] and that old guy yes
yes yes yes all I have a picture of him
like the guy who looked like he would
have got away with if it was for all you
pesky kids yeah yeah yeah that guy is
creepy remember we did something how do
you know about that guy we did something
for the naughty shame and you've
literally told me this story a thousand
times I'm done telling a story I lose my
goddamn mind this episode is called the
[ __ ] story never told
so anyways you're on your first date
with your wife hi welcome Amy's untold
pikake
me covered and calm like disappointed I
know I bet your brain that emerges so so
you guys go there so we go there we walk
in there's 30 dudes they always provide
Pizza Hut and like dr. pepper and stuff
for all my sponsor and one sock yeah
like no just in and make Lube and stuff
so every scene there Chelsea walked in
there like [ __ ] yeah they all think
she's the girl I'm like no this is my
girlfriend like I start pushing the guys
away oh my god I swear to god that
monster it's monstrous dude you have 40
dudes I think they're gonna get nervous
he's like oh no no if you I got it all
yeah bring this like cool let me see
your dick and guys we're whipping out
their dicks
let me see your dick jackoff and at
right Susie saying that I sort of got a
laugh and I was just like I just started
having a panic attack I grab her I go
I'm having a panic attack come outside
with me I go outside I start having a
panic attack I'm like she's like let me
see your dick Oh what are you working
with what are you working on so now I've
got a roomful of guys 30 dates all
jacking off and she's like [ __ ] cuz
oh my Zion he's like Leena Orchestra
yeah whack whack whack whack whack
[Laughter]
sports what one guy with simple spam
[ __ ] boys come in so everybody files
into this room and the [ __ ] starts
they start you know jerking off on this
girl and I'm so now watch her situation
uh she is uh naked and just like her
husband's there to write her husband was
the boom mic and he's like yeah yeah
yeah I know that they're recording it
for a video oh okay I'm just reaching
giggles it's for a video and so so
everybody's like the [ __ ] starts
every going crazy and I'm just holding
Chelsea slowly but surely it starts to
wrap up after like 45 minutes the last
guy pops she's covered in [ __ ] I'm
sitting there with two film how much
come true oh so much calm I know one to
ten ten being like I'm 11 you're gonna
die I'm 11 or 12 she looks like what
like a fight ice cream sundae an ice
cream the sound guy goes you're just
gonna sit there I'm you're just gonna
sit there and [ __ ] watch my wife can
calm down and not participate Oh like
dude that's not me I'm dating her like
that me and she said you can go come on
her and I was like I don't want him you
know Chelsea said go for it she's like
go for it that's fine I'm we're at a
[ __ ] I goes yes disrespectful dude
you're just gonna see you're like a
creep and watch my wife and not
participate you know and I was like
bizarro world is young I mean I can't
even really have you imagine my head
around my Eddie told me that the other
day dude you can't just do a podcast and
not come on my wife take it easy your
ex-wife your ex-wife is this gonna ruin
my chances of being a movie oh not a
[ __ ] baby trying to cobble listen to
international bad boys no Ozzie can I
not be in movies with this story no a
lot of movies they're just all black you
could be Hugh maybe stars stars yeah you
probably do some weird like basic cable
[ __ ] you guys he's nervous
you guys are not
I'm saying this has these meltdowns
every now and then too so it's funny to
see it switched around were you like I
can't run from I can't be like no
hangover five no look at re re can do
whatever he wants
alright you can do whatever it's not in
movies oh yeah right here
captain [ __ ] is not a Marvel comic I
really Steve it's over
just let go pain is past hockey movie
that turns left no forgotten movies
yes movie gone it's gone Sam that's not
true ABC Family I'm in an acting class
right now I don't have an ABC Family or
like a situation but I think you can be
an actor grazin [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] with me am I not because
your actors do like people do people do
okay I not be in movies play the movie
you want B and I'll tell you whether
you'll be in it 105 mm maybe a small
room you can I get to be like what about
[ __ ] 72 you could be an Anna no you
don't want a story okay it's a [ __ ]
story
no I don't want finish it movie star I
mean the heroine would probably he'll be
a movie star no but I know the ending
because I listened to the podcast so can
i yeah you guys don't want to be in
movies go ahead and finish it name
another movie
well you'd like to be in how come he
can't be in comedies no I'm over five
blows my mind well that George Clooney
over here take a chill pill and why
don't you guys finish it
come on but name another movie
Terminator set did that's all it's the
best joke of the [ __ ] thing um I
don't know let's see like what's a cool
Sandlot too ya know ya know a lot to
electric yeah why why cuz that's for the
children see nothing with children yeah
no yeah
no no Jamie no a next another one
another one name another one like a
David Lynch movie like wow yeah like
twin peaks' yeah no no no I don't want
to do this anymore like I have a vision
board of my mind and you're coming and
taking every picture all I'm doing that
yeah the guy who encourages you all the
time yeah you're doing that guy he's
doing me being serious right now are you
joking I'm you're my favorite megastar
thank you you're my favorite main star
thank you because your opinion matters
dude thank you can finish the [ __ ]
story it doesn't how about you finish
the story do you feel pressure like it's
your we talked to you on the phone star
now did you feel pressure like everybody
yeah hi Chelsea like yes on your
birthday yes yes and she's telling you
to do it yeah I'm impressed and all the
whole crew is like do it and this guy's
holding the boom he's like [ __ ] do it
that's this respectful if you don't do
it and I go if this chick sucks my dick
then I'll do it Chelsea just dropped to
her knees started sucking my dick no
show I swear to God
what I didn't remember this part yeah
you're like I would have told you to
tell this the whole time yeah and so
then I'm like sitting there like like
looking up I was like sponsoring like
three guys in a 12-step program I'm like
bro this is what the [ __ ] and you're
also on your first date with which is
now your wife yeah girl you really were
pining over for long yes yes yeah yeah
so on your first date you go to a
[ __ ] party where she starts blowing
it yeah and so then it said then
everybody knew you wanted to marry her
with the intentions you had humming on
another person yes yes Johnny would just
test you text me finish the [ __ ]
story so okay so is you Johnny um so
that I I she's sucking my dick and I'm
like oh my god I can't believe I'm doing
this but it was like kind of erotic by
the whole weirdness of it over yeah come
on the girl's face and all the crew goes
[ __ ] one of us now one of us now and
then the guy goes give me the [ __ ]
handshake and elbows me and it just
tripped something in my head and I
started hysterically crying and I ran
out of my remember that
and she came out and she started crying
I'm like I'm not this guy anymore
I love you I just wanna help people
I just want to heal and started
hysterically crying to be held each
other I'm so glad we got to the end of
this I'm like this is wrong we held each
other crying hysterically in the car and
that's how I know like dude I'm not a
swinger dude oh you already came so then
the next night I'm working in the main
room I'm in the back with Adam in like I
think yeah some of the shore I love
[ __ ] car gym I'm sitting in the back
in the back green room just working and
hanging out at my phone Twitter and I'm
not big on Twitter dude like my Twitter
starts blowing up and I'm like what is
this this is bad you know and it's
texting all the porn stars who just
happened to be at that [ __ ] that
white girl
welcome to the [ __ ] family at Steven
random Angela see skin word is book dude
block block delete delete like they were
all just trying to pull me into this
online community there and now just
[ __ ] so I was like ah no I think they
shot this so you actually run video well
I didn't take an AIDS test which highly
illegal and I did not sign a contract so
I don't know if I'm in the video or not
that videos her name the Jenna white it
was her last Akane you've never looked
it up I'm not gonna look it up Johnny it
was John he's already watched it I'm
gonna type in Jenna white [ __ ] I
could just imagine the sound guy look at
the boom mic and it looks like he dipped
it in white chocolate you know looks
like one of sherry carries
cherries berries we have that from uh 61
I'm a mom now I need my berry my berries
so dumb
I'm so [ __ ] I love the misspellings
on pornhub just Jenna take a [ __ ] shower
you know how on wedding websites it
tells the story of how you met was that
your ghost story for your families to
use we had some funny [ __ ] on there and
we decided cuz we were just like on a
manic high one night we were putting the
truth on there like yeah we met her to
clean this up I think that Chelsea's dad
jerked off to that porno one night I'm
cold
Oh Samuel Samuel finally my brother I
was great last night was amazing Randy
is always on yeah yeah it's the best
part about you know Santino and grin is
easy are perfect for that show they
really are they're just hilarious best
part of the show I don't know that's all
it was a great memory
it's all great we're gonna Phoenix this
week does that's cool in Vegas town
Figgis what are you doing in pinks we're
doing stand-up live and then in Vegas
we're doing and the dive bar I don't
know if you've ever you've probably been
there before probably Stanhope usually
does it's like a little rock places the
next place when I play Vegas I'll play
the vinyl at the Hard Rock I wanna play
camels new club oh yeah they try it I
want to check that I want to top that -
yeah comedy club plays just open yeah
that's old town yeah which is perfect
for yeah yeah yeah I like that area
yeah me too it's really fun I had the
best sandwich there's a Vegas me too
right next door to the golden sear
there's this Israeli sandwich place the
best sandwich I've ever had in my life
yeah I did the month stream yeah that
where Kimmel's fan open yeah that's
right yeah that's so smart it's so smart
it's way better than the strip I thought
the strip I love it more
Vegas is problem is that the banks and
the corporations are now nickel and
diming everybody and it's gonna I mean
do they're charging you for parking
Fremont is fun though
Dom I mean like like all the are late
and stuff like that geezers all that
that's why many bucks a night I'm like
use your nickel and diming everybody
you literally now thanks to the resort
tax and now you're like spending $70 a
day just unlike just to beat you but
[ __ ] yeah yeah when you see I could be
spending on gambling or buying food or
going to shows that's when people stop
coming around so I could spend $70 a
night on [ __ ] or I could say my my
hometown and go some Indian casino
that's getting better and better and
better and not have to leave the [ __ ]
house and that's what's gonna end up
killing I heard some of those Indian
casinos are really cool did the one down
by San Diego yeah didn't say yeah that
was it the Pala or what they called em
or Regan Regan brain go Chyna Marengo I
love that Marengo malanga
yeah that was awesome like some of those
that's won by all those like in Borrego
interesting place some is Reno
I think Reno's raw just ripe for a [ __ ]
it really flip never been there yeah
senator Geary affection everybody get
your casinos in Reno you know it is why
it's it's you like you like Fremont
Street you love Reno great one big free
monster yeah I do like Sacramento you'll
love if you like Fresno and you'll love
Reno you like Oxnard Oh Johnny found it
and then I'll make a gift we do you and
your wife make sex videos at home now
like is that Oh feet ney calls me up I'm
sick dude stop licking feet dog has
nothing to do look at that here you go
great bro
I've been going great
strap I got told last night my hair is
going gray I'm straight I did not know
about surprise I mean I know my face is
gray oh you gotta get justify any just
put it on your beard like I don't mind
it I don't mind it on my beard but I
don't want my hair to go guys Johnny
wants to know what the room looked like
because he says there's lots of videos
oh really what the room looked like all
there's multiple [ __ ] I'm fine right
now a cocky 68 you mean that's more than
one [ __ ] 68 well they just green
screen so you don't really know I'm
trying here I'm oh I know how to find it
what'd I tell you I'll look at no just
the still Johnny said she's the George
Carlin even funny anymore
dude I'm killing okay I just wanna go to
bed wow this is good like to move Sam
threw his back out at a [ __ ] dude if
you don't move so this is good you're
out of what is that and those photos of
it yeah so let me see let me see
no I don't this guy gets it what is it
photo though I feel fear of missing out
oh man why do you trust him oh why don't
you trust me with your phone
Nick why don't you trust me with your
phone girl because come on Black Hawk
Palm City I know that's so [ __ ] 2005
19 dad lost his [ __ ] on the show like
two months ago
it stopped coughing wait wait wait I
have a question and people keep hitting
me up about this Chad now has taken over
punch-drunk social media yeah what all
he does is tweet and post [ __ ] about
Chad sumac and now he's complaining I
just got him yelling from caspere's so
that I just went off on it so did I like
he's going on
what Instagram serious yeah well we're
fine Sam you got to get your [ __ ]
together pass
that's not that's weird there's never a
follow Sam
Chad Zuma Chad punch dunk is blowing
Chad Zuma cop Chad I wonder how long
happened we're cool now i knots on him
yeah I went nuts on happening
no I was working at the backdoor and you
know what the international bad boys
blowout and he decided to uh you know
take out Chad no I didn't know who he
was really at the time like I I didn't
know and he was like yo I'm Sam's friend
I get to get in and the management just
come back and they're like not another
body in this building I don't care if
it's a paid regular were swelling not
another body he's like hey dude I'm
walking into that I was like hey you
can't
and then he [ __ ] gave me attitude and
I was like bro it was me it was me I I
went crazy but like they were like hey
dude you know like Adam or whoever will
come out and be like dude not another
person you just gotta be you have one
job they're not any more person another
person walks in that main room you're in
trouble and so it's like hey I'm Sam's
friend I'm Pauly's friend doesn't matter
and so I didn't know who I was and so I
freaked out on him but it was me and I
apologize and yeah and I and I saw it
but I saw him and we're it's been a
couple years so officially I officially
apologize to mr. Zhu mock yeah it was my
fault I was an asphalt could have been
nicer about the way I express that to
you boy you got a punch drunk social
media you will accept your apology
yeah I've on punch now yeah I mean we're
just crazy people yeah we're all crazy
yeah I agree totally agree with that
yeah I'm fine yeah except for red band
fine red band is not crazy or not you
get naked mate dude you're not alive you
know there's a then you know the naked
maids vans that are there's a new wine
he's very up on this there's the new one
back page prose yeah it's like there's a
new back page have you been to the new
back [ __ ] it's like one guy and it's
add 40 times like even if you go women
for men or it doesn't matter it's just
one guy with the shirt off like I think
it's just one guy that wants to get laid
that guy has a vision and he went
through with it is doing it yeah now
it's on next door and all my neighbors
want it out of our
Burbank you're right in front of our
Starbucks and it's just like had to walk
my kids and ex to it and they're going
on their phones to Backpage pros calm my
kid had a log on a Nazi good quality
[ __ ] did you makin maids I got it yeah
I got it hurt this story we'll watch the
other room that it was it was like it
wasn't the one that's popular now but
when that one first came out there was
all these knockoffs on Craigslist and
you were too cheap to buy the [ __ ] yeah
and this was just a bad one it was just
like a woman and his daughter I guess it
would be I don't I talked about that the
ones I get that are popular they're not
even like they're just like oh I have my
top off and they're not even cleaning
they're just dusting yeah Wow no I'm
like clean my [ __ ] house and
put your shirt on while you're at it and
make me a sandwich yeah where does that
not that's a pun Chuck has changed you
know it's crazy I know I got a guy that
he does sex phone lines though like
hotlines and he like that's the saddest
thing that it's lately this day of age
you're calling a sex he calls them or he
works that well he calls them okay and
so he has like he has like he would like
Instagram it once in a while what it
sounds like and it's just you could tell
it's just like one old lady from like
Wisconsin just single oh yeah so honey
like who good call who can do that
that's like one Erica yeah me and Taylor
we uh I bought my friend on my credit
card four minutes for his birthday when
we were on math Wow hard more god I wish
I could have party with you back in the
day Jesus Christ meth heroin tweaking
he's like it's my birthday and I'm like
here's my credit card you got four
minutes on a 900 number and he's like
thank you I said an egg timer in the
kitchen dude have you ever called I had
never Cory of your
of just your life that's gonna be the
movie that you could star in your own
movie about your own loss you write a
book - yeah it's called I survived the
[ __ ] did you ever do needles like
yeah he does it kept me it kept me
looking younger I think heroin heroin
does that maybe I should start usually I
did yeah you should start doing a heroin
mom I want to be in Disney movies dude
real a [ __ ] phone why do you have
that fun really really well you and baby
I just like how little my phone is
really but generally does need a phone
cuz he's been out of storage for two
years and it does like the camera does
he have the same mild one yeah yeah
please yeah I think I think I have it in
my in my his phone is older than mine
his is a four you know you can just take
it for free they don't give it for free
they're expensive
no the nowadays you do nowadays nowadays
don't feel sorry for you yeah what the
newest latest one but you've got they
got like why not use one this is like a
thousand-dollar phone or something and
it's just like 20 bucks a month added to
my phone yeah it's [ __ ] worth it
mm-hmm I mean this is my everything
yeah but I feel that about my I know Wow
why do you have Netflix on there if
you're a vision board I don't want you
to take any more of my [ __ ] vision
board Netflix wants some come gossler
heroin addict I thought we were cool you
try maybe Hulu as a back I love see some
sea salt [ __ ] Donnie see so yeah they
should have made sardar i adult part of
hulu yeah hey here's the here's the
family stuff if you want a little edgier
joy not charge you more
see so just hang that funk around it
where you just knew it wasn't gonna work
I don't know what to say about because
everyone's like the wrong joke cause
it's so so right but it's like no I just
made that up but the point the point is
that they should have just they're
charging you extra it was part of Lulu
they want to charge you extra she just
made it a separate part because they're
done on some great specials Joey Diaz
Fahim otherwise yeah yeah Brent Weinbach
yeah the people they had are great but
it was just something about the Weinbach
or I didn't like the name the name and
wasn't it like a like an app or
something I don't have to work to see
something yeah you don't like working
I'm a workaholic you see he has a day
job I was so and a night job well kevin
Blatz calling we're selling [ __ ]
process and that's just the site thing
no I don't even talk about that yeah
yeah yeah you plug it on this if you're
an e-commerce merchant you're operating
some risky verticals I'm talking about
gaming I'm talking about guns and ammo
tobacco kratom CBD I'm your gun porn
big-time cams I will help you process
take payment online credit card don't
lose customers credit card is important
I will help you provide a gateway to get
that money
call me DME steven randolph so you have
like 100 $800 well yeah what you think
having our rug store so it looks like
you're just getting charged at a rug
shop instead of like no there's
different ways we do things and we're
above board we're a hundred percent
honest and we just know because my
company's half owned by payments
attorney we play by the rules
but we know what those rules are and we
operate it within the confines of the
law but we believe i don't care what
your political views are i don't care if
it's machine guns we're gonna help you
get those to your customers okay are you
a serial killer
no hey dude you got you have gun
companies we provided I believe that
everybody should have process access to
processing that's what our forefathers
thought that everybody should be able to
use a credit card yes dude that was one
of the amendments yes yes yes Discover
Card I want to get in the first answer
on tinfoil hat really yeah
Wow that's a good idea yeah I know a lot
of people guns is a very important issue
burbank there's one right down the
street there's a gun a lot of gun shops
there's a lot of gun stores out here hey
you want to sponsor podcasts yeah that's
cool
throw me money and I'll [ __ ] push
your product [ __ ] hard
was this a good episode Ives okay yeah
really no it's great one of the first
made it put it over the top
do you have any questions I know all
about the claws it just it gets me wild
up every time why I just I get why he
does it but I also just want you know
you know once it rips you just get
another one you know that why do you
ever wear non ripped clothes that's
beyond repair
what if it's actually cold though yeah
yeah it was cold here this winter I mean
okay you were a scarf a jacket a sweater
you're bundled up dressed like a hobo
that comes inside you dressed like a
Juggalo dad Wow all right kids enjoy the
Juggalos show dad will be here in two
hours
don't do anything I wouldn't do twice
the chemistry teacher would always say
that don't do anything I wouldn't do
twice yeah every Friday you tell us that
how many people go on the road with you
it depends which city like usually it's
me and Tony and one band member in one
band member so Jeremiah or Joel
depending on who can do it but like
closer places like Phoenix we usually
bring the whole band but Grateful Dead
so if it's like a plane or no plane it
depends how how how expensive it is
because it's you know we can't bring a
whole band if it's gonna cost you know
$700 each a plane ticket and then hotels
and stuff like that
it really depends yeah grab em hmm yeah
right who [ __ ] the most that would
probably be Jeremiah you know he's a
kinky [ __ ] I just did his
podcast but it was a blouse the the
Christian guy was super Christian dude
yeah I was loving him yeah he's married
I would love married him have sex yeah
he's gotta be weird cuz he's got that
giant nose so he can't look great at her
I would like to watch your my [ __ ] I
don't know what that is you would be the
number one guy you want to watch [ __ ]
what Jeremiah would be Chloe I just want
to see you know the characters come out
yeah probably charm our neighbors I'd
love to see you mom that's you violated
my Holtzman would be great watch my
Argos Hamilton targets Hamilton Josh
violence have you guys just you know I'm
sorry have you heard the story you I
apologize Gebo have you heard the story
about Josh meyerwitz losing his
virginity to someone also with
Asperger's and they both didn't know
when to stop it's the most incredible
story of ever it's incredible like your
Bible that kind of incredible income
because that's what they both just
didn't have the social cue to note when
and it started me he pulled it to me in
his caught in the car what I would give
him a ride home one night it was I was
like wait a second was it Meyerowitz the
one that that we all plays yeah that's
true maybe [ __ ] not because that's when
me and mater and Dave Taylor and and
Richards was she Heidi when we had to
show that later on actually became the
Rose battle was she hot I don't know she
was uh like a like a rub-and-tug kind of
prostitute vegan drug into rub-and-tug
when are you gonna do trans walk this
week when John gets back well what about
just walk didn't wait for when Johnny
it's bad so way back tomorrow he gets
back to my so when you wanna do with it
let's do next Tuesday okay I can do next
okay next Tuesday he's got he lost a bet
oh and I'm getting the shock collar
we're gonna knock that off
oh [ __ ] that shock
Scholarship we're knocking off we gotta
bang these all out so and get back to
these bets you almost just paid yours
off no you did stop stop you need to
know what I'm [ __ ] talking about yeah
but you know I'm not having your phone
for five days yeah that's what I'm
saying
oh I bet I'm saying you Ren is easy one
you don't [ __ ] oh yeah okay I get credit
for it do you think we're gonna be with
our phones for the rest of your life
very early yeah well I could be a phone
you know it would be like a I wear
really honestly yeah that's gonna be the
norm that yeah something like that or
like a hologram thing that comes out of
your neck like Iron Man Thing I think
you're right and you're but can't you
believe like they always to carry these
things around yeah I already have like
legged whatever you know carpal tunnel I
don't like I have carpal tunnel just
from holding this my left hand
definitely is different than my right
hand my left foot it's a great movie am
i right I've never seen it okay
all right guys for the final minutes
we're gonna go around and everyone's
kind of gonna give what they learned
about today what'd you learn I don't
know when you put me on the spot what
would you learn from today I didn't
learn anything anything nothing about
[ __ ] zhh rip clothes anything there
was so much discussed Steve's movie
career what like there's so much we
discussed I learned at Randolph there's
gonna be a movie star yeah you've always
believed Jason no one else did you did
thank you come guzzlers going to be a
mess would you like the [ __ ] story
was incredible and I you know I think
the studio should be all for their
actors having experienced such things
no guys an anarchist would you learn to
that I learned that Chris has a car and
he's not homeless because I saw him here
I learned I learned a little bit about
his clothes he's been a mystery to me
yeah um so I connected with him a little
bit
I learned that Candice is doing great
she needs to update her phone I learned
that I learned that Sam fights in these
wrestling things that I want to get
involved with I've learned that red man
doesn't believe in me and I learned that
Jason Tebow does okay
well besides the come guys Larry heroin
addict that's sitting next to me that's
never going to make it in the movie wait
a minute I'm right here
I learned that I didn't have to give any
sports at all today make some great back
there we go thank red banner always
bringing a holiday you know podcasting
Jason I learned that Sam was without his
phone for five days yeah rising to me
I like a fan that has a bad back and I
apologize and I hope you feel much much
better thank you and once again I
learned that Aaron is going through a
very difficult divorce and Aaron I'm
very sorry I've learned so much okay
yeah I've learned the rules of [ __ ] I
learned the inland California shadiest
[ __ ]
I learned that people can still use the
iPhone 5 I learned that you can't judge
someone based on their holy clothes
I learned that Steve runs easy and
Andrew Santino work really well together
and what a Darrin learn learn today
Aaron Aaron learned you need a
microphone to be on a podcast guys is
even one of the best punch stroke sports
ever can i okay is it your credit card
just listen I'm trying to get my podcast
numbers up so deep podcast with steven
randolph this week we just had on funk
ow i just so deep so deep podcast is
steven randolph so d follow me at steven
randolph to ste v and our aandl ph2 on
twitter and instagram and if you need
credit card processing [ __ ] calm oh
I'm at the Comedy Store 8 o'clock Friday